[Music]
new data is in regarding the recovery of
small businesses who say their
definition for success
will be when they're able to pay all of
their employees a full salary without
concern
this data is from cabbage it's an
american express company that is
tracking small business growth across
the u.s through next year
it found 57 percent of the small
businesses surveyed
say their businesses are now fully open
as local and federal shutdowns ease
keep in mind there are 30 million small
businesses across the nation
about 90 percent of them have fewer than
20 employees and 80 percent have fewer
than 10 employees
small businesses in general account for
50 percent of our non-farm gdp and 66
of all new jobs that are created
co-founder of cabbage catherine petralia
says there are great government programs
to help these small businesses recover
only a small percentage of small
businesses took advantage of the
paycheck protection program
under the cares act and there's now a
second round available so if businesses
took the first round
and they may be eligible for the second
round and if you never took a route if
you never borrowed under the program
most of those loans are going to become
grants and it's a great opportunity
to get some capital that will help
bridge the gap
also from the data a third of the
businesses surveyed plan to expand their
digital operations to either supplement
or
altogether replace in-person operations
overall many agreed they would consider
adopting new technologies to run their
companies more efficiently
you can read the full report on our
website at 8newsnow.com